hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking game from the st.
Louis rapping Hamlet's tournament this
is the rapid section as usual first
we're gonna have the three days of rapid
it's 25 minutes for the entire game plus
10 seconds delay from one I think the
the price point is some 150,000 dollars
with thirty seven and a half thousand
dollars for first row for first place so
it's round one it's ding leerin versus
magnus carlsen let's check it out and
enjoy the game as it's really really
just a beauty so without further ado
ding opens with d4 and for those who are
wondering and for those of you who miss
meadow in the background I will not be
returning to my hometown for a few more
days so up until then we will have
recordings from this room so sorry about
that but you know we work with what we
have the four biding we have Knight to
f6 by Carlson c4 e6 and of course we all
know where this is going knight of three
and d5 the Queen's Gambit a client is on
the board we have nice to see three and
Carlson goes for the air goes in defense
with Bishop to b4 Bishop to g5 by ding
and now D captures on c4 and of course
being goes for he for preparing to
recapture and c4 with a development of
the light square Bishop b5 Carlson
defends it and of course a for the in
the usual way you wanna attack the b5
point if black tries to defend his c4
pawn with c5 by Magnus and now a capture
some b5 now again ready to recapture on
c4 with C capture Sundy for by Magnus
Knight captures on d4 you have to
capture it and mount h6 asking a ding do
you want to capture on f6 or do you want
to go back dingos Bishop the back to e3
and now Knight captures on e4 now with
the wood the idea of just capturing on
c3 so Queen to c2 being defends it and
now Bishop to b7 calls and puts his
light square bishop on this beautiful
diagonal finally Bishop captures on c4
comes and now there is one game where
castles was played in the database but a
magnus goes for Queen to c7 just
attacking the light square bishop and
this is not a new move in
position but also it's very interesting
can you somehow take advantage of let's
say capturing here maybe take advantage
of this beautiful diagonal here not
really because if you capture on c3
after B captures on c3 black is just
lost you have to do something about your
dark square bishop for example if you
play Bishop to b6 then you get Knight
captures on e6 this is the idea and now
there's just no no coming back from this
if you capture Queen captures and g6
with check comes you have to play King
to f8 and then rook to d1 and there are
too many threats in this position for
example if you try Queen to e7 just
unpinning maybe getting Bishop to c7
hoping for Queen f6 to trade Queen's
Bishop captures on e6 comes and now
let's say Bishop c7 doesn't work yes
you're up a piece but let's say Bishop
c5 and the black is lost even if you
don't capture the bishop you could lose
a queen or even worse Queen to f7 will
be made because the DAR the the Queen
dark square the dark queen is pinned one
of the ideas so here instead Queen to c7
attacking the bishop and now the Queen
to b3 ding defense the bishop also puts
more pressure on the e6 square and now
cross and trades special characters on
c3 also the bishop on b4 was under
attack
B captures and c3 and now finally
causing castles
we have castles by dink and now cousin
goes for rook to c8 it's a nice idea
attacks the bishop on c4 also if the
bishop moves the c3 pawn will be under
attack
the downside is it leaves the rookin a8
underdeveloped and it will be somewhat
difficult to get this rook into the game
so butter back to d3 and here cross and
goes in Knight the c5 it's interesting
that if cost and goes after the pawn
with Queen captures here he loses the
game here ding held in mind Bishop
captures on e4 just grabbing a piece and
now after you grab the piece back Bishop
captures on e4 you get rook a c1 and
this is not a problem you either have to
give up the Queen the bishop guards the
c1 square or you capture the Queen but
then first white captures with check row
captures King h7 only now you recapture
and you are up a whole rook
so not possible instead Magnus goes for
the double attack he attacks the Queen
and the bishop on d3 and decides to get
rid of the light square bishop not only
is it
very strong piece but also it you know
gets the dings bishop pair of the board
we have Queen to be one night captures
Queen captures and now Knight to d7
getting the rest of the pieces developed
Queen to EP by Magnus not allow unite
see four five or a five to come with an
attack on the Queen also ding wants to
play queen g4 with a threat of Bishop
characters on h6 stop Carson continuous
development night the b6 this Knight is
not coming to c4 and we have let me just
improve this we have Queen to g4 as
mentioned Bishop captures on h6 is the
idea with Kingdom sorry King to h7
defending and now comes a bishop to f4
the bishop on f4 is a very nice move
because it comes with an attack on the
Queen and also it prepares knife to c6
where this point if it becomes a passer
on c6 c7 will already be guarded by the
bishop so very nice Queen to c5 by
Magnus and now rook F the e 1 we have
Knight to c4 by Magnus and now rook a to
d1 all of these pieces are now fully
operational and now Magnus has to waste
a move if he wants to get to this rook
into the game so rook the d8 this rook
is no longer useful and c8 and now rook
the d3 a very nice route cleaved by
doing this rook now can come to g3 and
threaten some mating ideas we have Queen
back to e7 preparing well some if the
bishop moves for example Queen g5 would
have trade a queen can come to f6 you
can push f5 the Queen will also guard
the g7 pawn so a lot of defensive
potential with Queen to e7 and here
Knight the CSIs by dink but also Knight
to f5 seems very interesting but it
doesn't work black comes on top in this
line even if you capture okay the White
Queen is also now under attack but Queen
captures and i-5 with check g6 blocking
check and now rook captures on e7 g
captures an f5 now you capture the F
pawn with check King g6 now you if you
capture you lose the rook on d3 so you
have to play rook d7 and now after
captures captures you'll get Bishop c8
and well black is up a piece white is up
two points but black will be better
so not something ding is interested in
96's plans now again this is a monster
night you have to get rid of it
Bishop captures and c6 and now before
capturing a nice efficient abiding route
captures rook captures and now big
captures on c6 and now we get the
position we discussed the Bishop from f4
guard c7 so c7 is coming and Magnus is
unable to prevent that we have Knight
the b6 at least guarding the c8 square
the queening square wood the night and
now comes Bishop to e5 already
threatening mate so here Magnus doesn't
like f6 ruining the pawn structure in
front of the King so instead Queen to g5
he offers a trade of Queens and now we
have c7 threatening to capture you could
try and trade the Queen's but here for
example if Queen captures on g4 you get
c capture son d8 and now it's it's just
bad for black I mean you're down the
exchange and you will not be able to
hold this there's no point in even
trying this so after c7 we have looked
d5 just getting broke out of the way
it's not a problem as the night covers
the queening square and now Quint efore
check now Dean has some very nice ideas
for example if you block with a 5 then
Queen B 1 with the threat of Queen
captures Knight just removing the
defender of the queening square so
Magnus tries a different plan Queen to
g6 or again trying to trade Queens but
how Queen to b4 again thing wants to
capture the night and get the other
Queen into the game but here Magnus
tries a very sneaky idea Queen to d3 and
now kenting captured the night and get a
new Queen into the game it's very
interesting for example if Queen
captures and now the Queen captures and
pawn turns into a queen do you see what
Magnus had in mind here
I feel free to even pause the video and
try to find a cousin's idea in this
position for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent exploiter of sneaky ideas and
for those who just want a good show
Queen e2 wins the game now you either
get Queen captures rook with checkmate
or if rook captures then rook d1 is
checkmate or if you try to rock f1 then
you know you're not out of the woods yet
rhudi
again the thread is checkmate and if you
capture the Queen captures rook with
checkmate and if you play h3 you just
get checkmated rook captures with chair
King here check grabbing the bishop here
check King g1 Queen e1 will be made so
not possible
you cannot capture first ding realizes
that there are back ranked weaknesses in
his position so first h3 now Queen
captures and b6 is definitely an idea so
Carson has to defend it Queen to b5
again offering a queen trade but again
ding declines it Queen to f4 check now
Carson's queen is stuck on the Queen
side and there is not all that much to
do there with f5 attacking the Queen and
now Queen to f4 now ding wants to play
Queen g3 followed by Queen to g7
checkmate we have Queen back to d7
preventing this also adding additional
protection to the queening square now
push up to D for not allowing Carson
rook to d1 to trade on pieces we have
Knight to c8 and the now comes Queen to
g3 here I think has a lot of ideas you
can just capture on e6 the Queen will be
unable to capture due to the checkmate
and g7 so here rook the d6 defending the
e6 pawn and also maybe now threatening
to capture on c7 as the rook blocks the
Queen's protection of the c7 square but
h4 biding and here you still can't
capture because rook captures on e6 will
just be super strong you're coming to g6
you can not capture because Queen
captures Queen so not possible here
across and goes route the c6 now again
hoping to win the pawn but h5 now then
wants to get to g6 so Queen f7
preventing that and now Bishop to e5
again the defending now the c7 point
twice with 9th to b6 and now finally
rook to a one being activates his rook
and hopes the now grab the a7 point and
here Carlsen doesn't really have a good
way of stopping that he goes Knight to
c4 now threatening to capture the bishop
rook captures on a7 with Knight captures
on e5 Queen captures on e5 and now
Carson is unable to capture on c7 as its
once again defended twice so he plays
Queen captures on h4
but it doesn't help him here again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning move for white in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent you know temporary sacrificer
of Queens and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show Queen captures
and g7 check this move wins the game
the King has two captured there's no
other option in captures and now c8
Queen with a discover to check from the
rook so black has to react to this
cousin play into f6 and now ding just
played Queen to d8 check and it was in
this position unmoved 45 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game because
whatever he plays he is getting checked
made it if King e5 then Queen to d4 is
made we get this position that we've
discussed a few videos ago where you
have this pawn structure it can be any
any piece any point except tonight then
the night covers the the mating square
so now everything here is covered nicely
and if you don't go to e5 if you go
somewhere in King to g6 which is the
only other idea Queens wait check King
of 6 and now you get the same meeting
sequence from the other side again the
pawns are blocking the king and the
Queen delivers in sorry about that
the Queen delivers mate again a very
nice structure so yeah this is a game
from round 1 Dean takes the full point
from Magus cross and full two points
because in rapid that you get two points
for a win
yeah a nice and I start for the Eliran
and Magnus will have to work hard to get
back into into the lead as he should I
mean he is the world champion so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
not gonna discuss who is playing in the
tournament or the standings so I'm gonna
show at least one more game from from
the day one so we're gonna discuss that
then and yeah that's pretty much it I
would like to thank Christopher Milligan
and Tariq RPF for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate that as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon you
know checking up on your suggestions
continuing the coverage of the st. Louis
rapid and blitz event and of course
enjoying my vacation here thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day